yeah you need a guy with a to be there
yeah because you need competency this is
terrible news it is terrible news for
all mediocre men who want to compete in
women's sports one of the things that
has happened uh is uh something tragic
actually yeah what was what's happened
that's absolutely tragic mate well trans
women yeah who are women as we know of
course they are and if you say they're
not you're part of a problem stop being
a slag and shut your mouth exactly we're
going to put you in a prison yeah if
you're a woman we're going to put you in
a prison and then put Isla Brian next to
you yeah exactly Bryson or whatever the
[__] her name is his name or whatever
well anyway let's talk about the latest
Battle of transphobia the world's
Athletics Federation not the world
economic Forum that's very different
yeah has banned transgender women from
competing in female world ranking events
and of course obviously outrageous mate
he's so outrageous they've got a bird to
write about it because birds love
friends but also I mean I don't think
they've sold this through to be honest
mate why no one's going to watch women
running around are they unless there's
someone with balls in the chat exactly
you know you need a guy with a dick to
be there yeah because you need
competency and you need a bit of
controversy as well you want to spice it
up get a lad in there you know what I
mean yeah look every combat sport or
anything to every sport needs a heel and
that is what they provide that is what
they provide yeah heal and testicles
exactly anyway let's have a little read
of this Anton find out what has been
going on there he is the first trans
woman ever to run in the world athletic
competitions yep also known as sebco
exactly look at him very distinguished
man so that joke it was inappropriate
the governing body's president and
all-round transphob Lord Co said no
transgender athlete who had gone through
male puberty would be permitted to
compete in female world-ranking
competitions from the 31st of March but
if you think this is transphobia there
is good news guys because what is a
woman is a difficult question yeah and a
working group will be set up to conduct
further research into the transgender
eligibility guidelines because no one
knows it's hard to know isn't it mate
yeah like if you've got a massive set of
balls on you yeah should you or should
you not be competing in women's sport I
mean no one knows well it's a difficult
one isn't it well the problem if you
like talking yeah and you keep doing it
yeah then maybe you are a woman and to
be honest this is the strongest argument
look we always like to play Devil's
Advocate on the show exactly there is an
argument to suggest that trans women are
actually women yeah there is a [__]
ban on a bit don't they oh they're
playing about it just all the time
just bang but just you know and they're
just carrying on with it and you just
eventually you know like Always a Woman
They just grind you down until you just
go you know what [__] have it go on
go just run with the one that's fine
[__] you know just just let me have my
Saturday we're not saying no forever
right we're gonna have it go away have a
little working group yeah have a little
think yeah right and then maybe we'll
decide the trans women actually are
women exactly that could happen that
could happen depending on how much
pressure we get put under on social
media yeah it depends how many meltdowns
we see on Twitter exactly uh which are
probably already happening as we speak
under previous rules uh World Athletics
required trans women to reduce their
amount of blood testosterone to a
maximum of uh five N More I don't know
what that is and stay alive moles per
liter yeah five moles per liter uh five
of me basically and stayed under this
threshold continuously for a period of
12 months uh before competing in the
female category Lord Co added the
decision was Guided by the over writing
principle which is to protect the female
category but you know what this is a
great point because a biological male
who has obviously gone through uh
puberty and has five moles or less than
five moles in his blood yeah I mean he's
obviously a woman obviously this
obviously has no Advantage the hip angle
isn't different their muscle mass isn't
different you know the structure of
their bones the ability to think clearly
you don't need that for running mate
well you know you know because here's
the thing you know when you're watching
female sports at any given moment
they're about five minutes away from
bursting into tears so you know that's
the advantage
look don't get pissed off with me
because I'm spitting facts you know it's
true and he said decisions are always
difficult when they involve conflicting
needs and rights between different
groups and to be fair we have always
encouraged kicking women under the bus
there we go well look this is this is I
mean terrible news it is terrible news
for all uh mediocre men who want to
compete in women's sports exactly
terrible you know it's just terrible
news we've been trying to make women's
sport more interesting for years yeah
and you know what people are just not
having it well we suggested shorter
shorts and and you know many times
you know former president of FIFA a
great man yeah he said short Assurance
for women yeah then we tried to inject
some men into it yes just to up the
competition a little bit give it a
little bit more spice yeah a little bit
more free song yeah right neither of
those things have been taken on I mean
do you want anyone to watch your sport
or not exactly yeah you know and people
like older women's NBA should be paid
like the men look that's only going to
happen if you get Men playing in it yeah
exactly so if you want a better salary
yeah become a man exactly oh just stop
moaning there's only one way to collect
them that's not going to happen yeah
there's only one way to close the gender
pay Gap yeah transition exactly
wait and don't complain right then you
know you say things like that it's not
fair yeah because we've given you
Solutions you know if you don't want to
take several several